Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house.
Christina Vincent.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Now Ladies and gentlemen,
Jane,
you're
main gene is getting back out there.
Okay.
I got some 2018 dates to announce.
I'm going to Denmark,
Iowa,
also known as demoines.
Uh,
what is it?
February,
February eight,
nine and 10.
I'm going to be at the uh,
days.
Moines funny bones.
And then also I added what you're going there to a sharp lake.
Teddy's,
no,
I'm going to start like Teddy's April 12th through 14th,
so I'll be there.
If you're in a either city,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash tour and get tickets short lake titties.
Dez Moines,
Iowa.
What else you got chain?
Uh,
January 12th,
my eight o'clock show sold out at the Ice House in Pasadena.
So we've added a 10 o'clock show.
So get your tickets now.
That is coming up soon.
That is this Friday.
So Christina p online for those tickets.
February 2nd and third salt February.
See I didn't say it right,
right.
You said it wrong.
February.
It's February,
second third short lake titties.
Puto at wise guys come in your face club.
February 23rd one night,
one show only Calusa casino and Colusa California.
March 30th and 31st Portland Horrigan at the hearing them comedy crab.
Cristina p online for your ticks.
Can you see athletes that the ticks,
it's like tax took some shorthand.
Yeah,
this is a,
what's it called?
Is this psycho funk shorthand by Eddie Bojangles.
You love it.
I can tell
you.
Love it,
Huh?
Yeah.
I can see you wearing your high heels shoes.
Dancing in this me and my sisters out on the town.
Feel you tonight.
Okay.
Did it again?
Any Bojangles you don't need no man.
Time to get into the show.
Gene.
Are you ready for one heck of a fun.
Yeah.
Ready?
Here we go.
Let's get into it.
Jean
[inaudible]
you fuck bitch.
Fucking bloody buster bent.
Lardy backed up.
You go black duck.
You know.
Oh was ranting.
Don't bring anyone loving to this.
Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house.
A quick reminder.
This happens as you know,
whenever something like this occurs,
but it is my duty and my obligation and duty,
duty and obligation to remind you that your boy t has a brand new Netflix
special.
Uh,
you can begin streaming worldwide this Friday,
January the 12th,
Netflix,
the specialist called disgraceful
and
have a worldwide.
I'm very excited.
Don't forget,
I get
to check it out and tell your friends,
tell your family what can people expect from this?
What can people expect?
One of my favorite interview questions about a comedy show it,
you can expect that I go for it.
Politics are going to be talking a lot of issues.
It's so funny.
[inaudible] they go,
um,
I hope you don't fuck up and do a bunch of Trump jokes.
Oh,
okay.
Right.
Cause that's what the year of the political comic or even like,
like,
but who are you to decide?
Like what's,
what's fucking up and what's not?
I mean like,
you know what I mean?
Like do you mean personally for you?
It would upset you.
Okay.
I hope you don't say anything that I take offense tail.
Like,
no,
that's not what I do.
But like he was my favorite.
I already don't like you.
Just so you know,
I have a son.
Yes.
Send me the criteria on hair.
Tell me the,
that your personal criteria for what the special,
exactly.
All the turns it should take and the topics it should tackle.
And then if they're like,
you know,
I was up,
I was up to you.
I was with you up until this point.
That's what they tell you.
Oh,
I've,
I've gotten those.
I had a guy who was,
so,
he loved my special until I made fun of Dick Clark and for him,
Dick Clark was the gold standard and he was very upset with me and well then he
liked a lot of it because that was the closing.
He was on board and then I,
I,
I lost him there.
So I,
I saw a lot of backlash for Chapelle,
you know,
so I haven't seen that too.
Then they're like,
you,
you know this top of,
then they also,
some people were like,
you shouldn't have done Trump jokes.
It's like,
why?
Why shouldn't he do it?
He wants.
Yeah.
It's like,
what are you talking about,
man?
Yeah.
He didn't like ask you,
what do you want to see?
And then when against your wishes he's doing his own show.
Yeah.
And also too,
you know,
with a,
I've been reading about the offense people have been taking,
not people,
I should say,
I should say the writers,
the,
uh,
the PC people they're going after Chapelle.
Yeah.
And,
and my favorite I read an article is like,
you know,
he's unsympathetic
to trans people and he should be more sympathetic to trans people of color.
Like,
as if to imply the Dave Chappelle is not only responsible for one type of trans,
but he should be thinking of the spectrum of all types of people with all types
of gender identity and,
and colors.
And like,
he can't be responsible for all of it guys.
Like he's just a man with his point of view,
trying to make some jokes,
jokes.
That's,
that's,
that's his job.
He's responsible.
He's responsible for going for jokes.
Yeah.
If he was like,
I'm not doing joke tonight,
and then you'd be like,
he's a very irresponsible,
right.
And he should be taking into account every person of color with a race and the
gender and the thing,
and it's like,
dude,
get give the guy find a break.
He's a funny guy.
He's a good entertainer.
Maybe it's not for you.
That's another option.
Yeah.
I always like to remind people.
Yeah,
that's true.
Maybe I'm not for you.
Maybe other people are not for you,
but there are a lot of options,
right?
Yeah.
How about that?
It's one of my favorite ones to say to people who write to me about Netflix when
they're like,
I didn't like this part of your necklace thing.
I always write back.
I wish they had other shows you can watch.
Right.
The catalog.
Just thousands of them without a sea of them.
But no,
I'm,
I'm actually,
I'm very much looking forward to it coming out.
I'm looking forward to everyone is a fun,
it was a fun tour.
This is a snapshot of like one of the best nights of the tour,
so I think it's going to be a fun special.
It was super funny when you recorded it.
I was there for that.
You look great.
Sounded Great.
I think the material is outstanding.
I think people are,
your fans are going to be very happy with this one.
I hope so.
It's a big deal.
I'll get off social media that day now.
I don't even come on.
You know I've read about some big actors.
They go to other countries.
Aren't you telling me that?
No.
I would tell you that ugly guy from star wars,
the one who plays?
Yeah,
he was on girls.
Oh,
that ugly guy.
Ugly.
By the way,
I don't know what it is about the star wars casting because we just saw the
latest installment and everybody's fucking dog city dog chow.
I don't know why.
Why they can't cast attractive actors to play.
Oh,
I know the leads.
I mean everybody's a fucking Bowzer on.
It's a dog pound would,
oh,
it's a bunch of dogs on there.
And then this actually,
that guy from girls,
Adam driver,
his name,
he is so ugly.
I don't even know why this is a leading man now.
He looks good there.
There,
that's a good photo.
But I mean,
look,
I'm not,
I personally,
I don't find him sexually attracted.
Maybe some women do,
but I feel like he's not very traditionally at some what's,
let's say that we're traditionalist.
We want you to be handsome the way we want it to be.
Handsome.
He looks good there though.
That's upsetting.
That's like a good photo of him.
He looks like a young Keanu there.
I don't disagree.
No,
but in the movie you're just like,
is there a way,
can you
put your mask back on?
That's what I want them to do because that guys like tag that re-discuss
ridiculous helmet.
I'm like,
have I put that shit back on?
Paint more of those black scars on your face.
Like the stitching?
Yeah.
He looked cooler.
What the scars on his face.
I thought,
yeah,
I don't know.
I was like,
anyway.
Um,
and no spoiler,
I'm not going to spoil or alert or any or whatever.
The word is you run the plot platform.
They,
Luke Skywalker does make an appearance.
Okay.
And we know that he was,
he goes to the island of the gurus or wherever he's from,
CIF for Far Island,
Ofac,
Rutgers,
uh,
now,
annoying to us as viewers.
They don't address the biggest issue,
which is how does he masturbate?
Because there's no internet connection.
There's no masturbation.
And there's also,
it's like there's all this high tech shit,
but he's not watching any porn or asking for porn.
Like even when he runs into another person,
he's like,
he's not like,
did you bring any porn with you?
So stupid.
Well,
and he's been there for so many years in there,
a long time.
It doesn't try to fuck,
he's not like,
what's up with your tits?
Like,
well,
there's no other humans there.
There's only reach runs into a human at some point and he's not like,
here you down.
Right.
That's fine.
Weird.
It's weird.
And he lives in like a brick hut.
So we,
we didn't get to see how he shits or where he shits switch.
I think that's the first question.
No bathroom breaks in any part of the movie.
There's aliens and people coexisting.
No one's like,
I got to go to the bathroom.
No one says I'm horny.
I want to jerk off.
No one tries to fuck anybody.
I,
nobody eats ever in these films,
which makes me crazy.
Like,
which I guess is the explanation for why they're not going to the bathroom.
But yeah,
it's really stupid.
Like George Lucas has a real fucking hole in this thing.
Major,
major plot holes.
Maybe they eat like military Mras that block them up.
You know,
like they're high calories.
That scene.
Where is this?
He,
yeah.
Where's that scene?
I mean,
they're the space ships and things.
Not like you see a spaceship where there's like a wookie.
Um,
where does he shit?
A couple humans,
another alien and no one's like,
hey,
we're up in the space ship right now.
Do you guys want to have an orgy?
Or like,
does anyone got a shit?
Well,
you'd think the wookie would take lucky size downstream would be horrendous.
And they'd be like,
get Outta here.
You know?
And they forced him the shit out of the side of the spaceship.
What is Chewbacca eat like?
They don't,
doesn't show him eating.
It doesn't show him,
by the way,
trying to fuck any women.
Which a Wiki you would look at and be like,
that's going well.
And it's annoying because he and c three Po or no,
R Two d two they both say the same phrases.
Oh Wow.
And then the other human understands it.
You're always,
oh,
you mean you want to go outside?
Chewy?
Yeah,
that sounded exactly the same as everything he's been saying for 20 years.
Maybe it's like Japanese,
you know,
they just granted a lot and you're like,
well that's a totally different phrase.
Yeah.
Japanese.
You're like,
that's the same thing.
You could just say sure.
Or Mandarin.
They're like,
she's bright.
And you're like,
okay,
what does that mean?
And they're like,
right,
that means we have lunch in 17 minutes.
And then you're like,
all right.
And then
you're like,
wait,
I know I heard you.
It's like,
no,
now I just said that the,
the car downstairs,
the tires are flat and you're like,
wait,
you just said 17 minutes ago.
So you're equating the wookie language with Mandarin or the R Two d two language
with,
with uh,
one of the oldest languages on the planet know
there's a lot of switching.
Sure,
sure.
Interesting know.
Do you think George Lucas studied Japanese and then wrote the language?
Well,
I was not doing Japanese,
Japanese one.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I,
my ear is not as tuned.
Does yours,
do you think there are people out there like,
you know,
how people learn cling on?
Do you think there are people that learn to speak Chewbacca language like their
schools?
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
And,
and the c three Po language or whatever.
Rtr People so dedicated to virginity being nerds.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
there's definitely that three Po.
I know.
It's one of the dumbest thing.
I think that happens,
you know,
but it's not,
I don't think it's fair to equate a Chinese or Japanese with the Wiki language,
uh,
Marcy three.
But I think that's pretty tricky to keep mixing them up.
R Two d two is the tiny one.
C three Po is the the goal uptight.
Yeah.
The no fun broke robot.
He's the gay robot.
Yeah.
He's totally gay.
Right?
Oh,
monster.
Luke.
Yeah.
He's,
he's very much like,
he picks him always going like,
oh yeah,
he's Fay.
Yeah.
Do you think so you think George Lucas wrote him is like the gay,
definitely a robot.
Speaking of accents and difficult to undo,
ladies and gentlemen,
Tom Segura,
master of,
so
let me tell you,
title has slipped off so much in the last couple of years.
What do you got to remind people?
First of all,
the open and clip was that my Stepdad,
people thought it was your Stepdad and they wanted to know if that's what it
sounded like when you were growing up.
Yes.
For people that don't know,
Christina grew up with an Indian stepdad.
That's not just an amazing reference.
Yeah.
And three Indian step.
So true.
And we ate a lot of curry and he talked lie shit.
Yeah.
Is that what it sounded like?
Let's go back.
No,
he didn't have a thick accent.
That the folder,
it says Christina stuff that arguing Chella yeah.
If you want those little go down.
Yeah,
you're fucking not fucking,
you are fucking fucking fucking
bitch.
I Love,
love this style of arguing.
Yeah.
Cause I think there's a chance that they both speak the same language and
they're,
they're refusing to get into choosing English yet and choosing the words.
The only words they know,
which is fucking fuck you bloody.
So we obviously live in the UK.
Yeah.
And uh,
look out in the,
a real anger is kind of scary,
right.
To be angry.
My stepdad used to get into altercations with strangers like this too.
You didn't speak like this,
right?
Not this.
No.
He spoke really good English.
He was from Bombay,
formerly Mumbai.
Could you hear the Indian accent?
Every now and then it would come out,
but it was not thick cause he came to the u s when he was like 28 years old.
It was pretty late.
I know,
but,
but you forget that they were taught English because you know the British took
over India.
So I'm assuming he learned English early in life.
Oh,
okay.
But yeah,
sometimes it would come out.
Who fucking knew he did that?
A lot of other fucker.
Ooh,
fuck dude.
Fucking guy.
Like that's how he's,
Oh fucking killed a guy.
Like he,
he actually sounded more like Midwestern.
I wasn't sometimes it was weird.
Your stories about him or absolutely terrifying.
I know he's dead now,
thankfully.
Yeah.
But he was a special,
yeah,
he was different.
But I mean maybe it's Indian guys,
they get really upset.
I think it's,
I do think it is cultural for Indians to become more animated and to use the
hand.
He did a lot of the hand gesturing that you see in the movies,
you know,
and the head bottling stuff he did that.
He was more this a gesture or what appears to be happening is the argument is
between the guy who's walking and the guy who was driving and the driver is the
one with the camera.
He seems more agitated because see this guy is like trying to tell him something
that Walker is.
Yeah.
And then the driver is like,
if you want to go,
then you'll go to Zillow.
Go down.
Yes.
He would just grab it.
See,
that's the reason it are you crazy.
That's really a lot of people's,
a set off point.
If you,
if you ask a crazy person,
are you crazy?
Yeah.
That's when they lose it.
You know,
you can't ask crazy.
Are you crazy?
Or you're telling him you're crazy.
Then they snap.
That's like the end of it,
man.
Yeah.
I got no fucking,
you are fucking fucking
bitch.
Fuck you.
Fuck you fucking fuck you.
Bloody fucking fuck you.
Fuck you.
Fuck Bitch.
Bloody bastard.
Have a bent toward blarney backed up.
Know Black Duck.
You know about.
That's uh,
that's almost like he reverted back to his,
his actual native tongue.
I don't know.
It was like,
fuck you.
Fuck you bitch.
Bloody fucker.
Then he's like [inaudible].
He's like,
no,
you fucking of right.
Isn't that what's going on?
That's what I heard.
It's
fucking bloody boxer bank toward bloody up.
Yeah.
Fine.
You so he,
they are speed.
They do speak a common,
went to the old school language and then he came back.
Yeah.
Fuck you bond.
Shoot.
Fucking bloody bastard.
Thank George.
Bloody up.
You Black,
you know?
Yeah.
I said to a point like that too.
So funny.
Yeah.
Same gesture.
So aggressive.
Yeah.
Good deal man.
The stories you,
you've told me,
he know he's really fucked up.
We used to,
I don't know if I told us one,
but we,
one time we stopped for p,
he used to love pistachio ice cream and we'd go get it Thrifty's which is the
rite aid.
Now.
One time we were go,
let's go,
let's go.
We a pistachio ice cream.
I go,
great.
We get in the car.
He goes,
hold on,
I got to do something.
Gets out of the car,
stabs at guy's tire,
gets back into the car.
We get pistachio ice cream and at the time I,
my mom was in the car and I was like,
did he just stabbed?
That guy is tired.
And My mother was just laughing and she was like,
well,
he fucking deserve.
That's all they had to show him this mother fucker.
I was like,
whoa.
There's some guy that he had done business with that.
How old were you in our law and set on fire once?
Uh,
he had his windshield shot out on the freeway by somebody.
He had done business with.
God.
It's different,
man.
Didn't pay taxes for like a decade.
That'll do it.
That's good.
Wow.
Fuck me.
I've talked to blahdy Blah.
Start walking around the lake lady.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
He says you're running like a lady.
Let's see.
He's pissed at this guy and then he,
oh fuck you.
Fuck you.
And like running like a lady in it because this guy's jogging I guess on the
side of the road.
As she's telling him.
He's telling me I'm a woman.
I love foreigners cussing people out.
It makes me laugh.
Bondi boss start walking around and like,
lady.
Yeah.
What the fuck man?
Lindsey,
that's a good thing.
That's a definitely a colloquialism.
Like the what the fuck man?
Yeah.
They pick that up.
What the fuck man?
It because it has the ending and he's like,
oh,
bloody bitch,
fucking fuck you mother,
mother bitch.
And he's like,
what the fuck man?
I got all say what the fuck man?
Yeah.
What the fuck man?
That's a lot of eighties movies.
Yeah.
What the fuck man?
Fuck no soccer DNA.
Why is talking at me?
Because I even going through the [inaudible] due to other places we got of this
doing hello?
I don't know.
You have to like this.
I think you have to go,
go into accident.
No,
sorry.
Not me.
No.
Good man.
Salting at me.
Yeah.
Salt assaulting me.
Oh,
assaulting at maybe he means you're assaulting me.
Yeah.
So great.
It's a great argument.
Yeah.
I think I like a foreign foreign arguments more than I like white trash
arguments.
So we play.
Yeah.
You know,
like
trashy white people.
I don't know.
This is more,
can be good.
It's fun like this because it's,
you know what?
There you can try to guess what they're trying to say and they're saying it kind
of wrong.
Wow.
Fuck me.
I you,
why you fucked me.
I fuck you.
Yeah.
To see what he's really trying to say there is,
why are you saying fuck you to me?
Yeah.
Fuck fuck you.
He said,
why you fucked me?
I fucked.
Yes,
it's fantastic.
That's a great way.
Imagine how hard it is.
Fuck me.
I've talked to Florida to get a good swear on in a,
in a second language.
It's damn near impossible.
But I did for you bloody.
Cause they also,
you know the Brits lots of bloody bloody that.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That's tough.
It's tough to get a perfect sweater.
You bloody bastard.
I've heard the joke before.
I don't know whose it is,
but like when you're scared,
you always go to your native tongue.
Oh,
that's interesting.
No,
I forget who did it so I can't,
but I heard somebody say that and I was like,
that is absolutely true.
Like
be,
uh,
speaking Spanish in Latin America and fully be rapping with people,
but like if somebody pulls out a gun,
I'm gonna
oh shit.
You know,
you don't,
you don't stay in the second tongue.
Of course.
You always go to your native tongue when you're in fear.
Well,
I wonder what my parents dreamed in what language.
I think eventually,
eventually it changes to English.
Yeah.
Eventually it changes to the what you're immersed in.
That's interesting.
Like you could probably have like I remember when I studied abroad,
I was dreaming English,
English,
but like three,
four months in it switched over.
Yeah.
Because it was all day every day.
That's crazy.
No,
nobody was speaking English so that's crazy.
You're just speaking Mexican all day long.
All Day Mexican.
Yeah.
My favorite story is your Senora that you lived with
and come down for breakfast.
Tell your story now.
I would to,
I would go to a
breakfast every day.
Uh,
I lived with an old lady I sent you are extending rights at us like you call
your mom.
She was like late seventies early eighties,
three American white boys and the other two had been there for a while before
me,
so they were doing two semesters.
I was only one.
So they did a full semester already.
So I got there and like,
I dunno,
it's like over a month into me being there already and we have,
we have breakfast and lunch together most days,
sometimes dinner.
Um,
but breakfast every day.
So I come out and I was like,
oh,
I'm going to,
uh,
I forget what city I'm going to like the leather or Toledo.
Yeah.
Or like Galeazzi or something this weekend to visit a friend's family.
And she's like,
oh,
that's nice.
And I go,
yeah.
She goes,
will you wear underwear to breakfast there too?
Because every day I would do,
what I always do is like,
I've just come out of my boxes,
which,
which is what you do at home,
right in front of the nanny had thought about it and she never said anything.
Yeah.
But she said it then I go and I'd right away I go,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I go,
I didn't know.
So from then on I always put on like sweat pants or shorts over my boxes.
Yeah.
But that was her way of letting me know.
Instead of saying something,
she's like,
well,
you wear your underwear to breakfast there too.
You rude American pig.
Yeah.
She was like,
Jesus,
man,
you're nuts are out at breakfast.
One morning.
I was like,
still do that.
It's like you're 80 you don't like it at all.
Of course.
You like it.
You do feel more comfortable in your mind.
I want to live in my boxers.
Yeah.
I love walking around in my boxers.
I bet.
Yeah,
That's nice.
I don't feel like women should have boxers too.
Yeah.
How come you guys get to have these like awesome shorts?
Basically you were on new year's stuff and then we have to wear like tight stuff
around our coaches and the truth is our genital suffer more by being seized up
like that are sealed in.
You want them to be able to breathe?
Yeah,
please.
You must.
It was my mother's big one.
You must let your vagina breathe at night.
Don't wear underwear when you get home,
you take off your underwear is sleep.
She just pluralized things and critically all the time.
Mom,
this too.
Yeah.
It's hard.
English is too complicated.
It's not an easy language.
There's words like a comb.
Yeah.
Comb Houmas.
CONB is bom B two mom and comb.
Right,
right.
So it's not gone.
He's gone home.
Yeah.
Just say whatever.
After you hear it,
you're like,
yeah,
that is kind of dumb that it sounds different.
This spelled the basically the same.
Yeah.
There's a lot of exceptions to rules.
It's really not an easy language to learn.
She still uses the wrong pronouns.
Yes.
Yeah.
She speaks pretty great though.
Be great considering like she'll say like,
I mean she's not a nonbinary,
but she'll refer it to like you as he and Mia.
She and I'm just like,
whatever.
Yeah,
let it go,
but it doesn't bother me.
It doesn't bother me.
I'm just like,
you still don't get it right.
Like 39 years.
40 some years in,
I guess.
I imagine like,
I don't know.
I guess it's so hard.
It is hard.
Well,
here,
this is the master of accidents I was trying to get to.
Oh,
okay.
Maybe you can weigh in since you're such a bragger now
fraud and first fuck you.
Nice noise on a hot day.
He's an alcoholic.
I think so.
Yeah.
Fucking dog couch.
VB.
It's,
I bet he says it's a cheap beer.
Right?
I can see the label.
The label starts with a v Victorian Beers.
Yeah.
So let's see what Sir
fucking Doug Carter first fuck is
for harder and thirst fuckers.
It's either that he's either saying that name or saying it fuckers.
Nah,
I can't really tell the hardened thirst fuckers.
Yeah,
dog.
Cause I like dog cons.
I've never heard dog content.
Never heard that before.
Really good dog comes.
Yeah,
it's really good.
I mean I have that.
Is that so intense fucking dog of,
I mean we've heard comments like the British say Khan Khan,
kind of a dog.
Cons.
Wow.
How does a good one,
I bet this guy is a real pig to women too.
Yeah,
I mean God,
can you imagine his me to list how long that shit is?
Hashtag dog kind of Scott is a savage peg for sure.
Don't cut.
Nice.
I know.
Hot Dry on this bit there.
Oh,
Victoria bitter VB.
that's what he says.
So that bitter taste nice on a hot day.
It's probably a better,
so does he say,
ah,
yeah.
Fuck her dog.
VB fucking dog.
But at the beginning here,
that's the only question it does he say
mother fucker or does he say,
uh,
betters this part here?
I didn't fish.
Fuck you.
Fuck is.
Oh yeah,
we're all fuck you's.
Yeah.
Fuck is he Australian?
For Hot and thirst.
Fuck you's.
Yeah.
Saying fuck you.
Okay.
He's not saying it better.
I think.
I bet you Victoria bitters is like a ghetto ass brand or something
first.
Fuck you.
Don't come
Doug.
Correct
guys.
Terry,
I wish I would not be surprised if they're like,
hey,
guess what?
This turns out this guy has a dungeon and it's out.
Of course he knows that there's been girls tied up there for years.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's,
Yeah.
He's like,
don't let any drip drop fall out of your mouth.
I'll cut your nipples off.
He's also got,
yeah,
that hard booze bag.
Look where he's really pale,
but he turns red easily.
This is decades consumption.
Decades.
Lifetime of alcohol.
Is he here?
I mean,
you've pointed this out a lot and now I'm starting to notice how people age.
Yeah.
Not so much that they age,
but it's in the how and you can really see how people have been living it
totally dependent upon like if do they look like this is their skin red
leathery?
Yeah.
They look like they've been drinking their whole lives.
Do they have the distended hard belly?
Oh,
this guy is on his lap.
I mean this guy is going to,
he's going to have a painful death,
you know?
Seriously.
I mean his insides are just going to melt.
It's probably got,
yeah.
Uh,
I give him about four years.
Yeah.
10,
10 bad years for good ones.
Six shitty ones on the way out.
That's fair.
You can also just see like who's avoid advice.
That's all it is,
is like have you been moderate in your life or have you been,
but then you have to go riding it hard.
Do you,
what?
What is joy?
Do you,
what brings you joy is for me seriously just drinking wine ain't no,
but I'm saying for some people that vice is life.
Right,
right,
right.
Speaking of that,
you just came back on it.
Yeah.
That was with the vice champion.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
To uh,
Atlanta for the national championship game,
by the way,
for those who followed a,
our weight loss.
And I remember Ari,
the Welcher for not paying his bet,
he more than made up for it.
He flew us out,
he put us up and he got unbelievable 50 yard line tickets,
like 20 rows up to the national championship game,
which if you did not see it,
you may have heard about it.
If you don't follow football,
it was hands down one of the best games ever.
One.
And certainly one of the best national championship games ever.
I mean,
we've had some good ones,
so we've had some great ones,
but that is right up there.
It went into overtime.
There was a comeback when we just had a blast.
We had so much fun.
I flew in on Saturday.
I went to dinner with the guys.
Uh,
Sunday we went,
we played,
uh,
top golf,
which is like this,
this thing has really exploded where you go and you get like a little bay and
you can hit,
you play games,
but you hit golf balls into an open driving range,
but from little bays and you order food and drinks and,
Oh,
speaking of drinks.
So you got to watch Burt drank for two or three days prior day.
So did you keep track?
So we started Saturday night,
we went out to dinner,
we all had a few drinks and then we went back to the,
uh,
you got an airbnb and we chilled there.
And then the next day we went to,
oh,
we went to brunch.
They really wanted to do a,
like a southern brunch.
That's fun.
So I started with Mimosas and um,
you know,
not,
I'm Burt had like three or four and uh,
I think Ari and I had one or two and then we go to top golf.
And so we,
we go there and he's just like,
I told Tito's and Soda,
Oh,
pretty pick up through mine and then starts just doing that.
I'm actually like,
I had a few drinks last night.
I'm a lightweight,
I go,
I just need to rehydrate it.
So I'm just drinking water,
water,
water wasn't the water God.
So okay.
So I'm doing that Ariz having bloody Mary's,
but he's having like one for every two doubles that has.
And by the way,
Burt's killing it.
He has a great golf swing.
So he's just like playing well so he has,
I dunno,
we estimate.
He was like,
I think I look five where like I think you had like seven and we settled on six,
which is being generous.
This is on Golf Day?
Yes.
So we leave there and then we go home,
have a drink at the house.
So He's another one there.
Then we go to a cigar lounge before dinner.
He has more doubles at
the Cigar Lounge.
Doubles Question Tom,
you were saying that birds drinking six drinks but he's drinking doubles.
Correct.
At each drink.
Right.
So it's actually 12 drinks when you're saying six.
Yeah.
So,
so have you have the,
let's say the Momos is,
let's not even count them.
What's this to say?
That just orange juice?
Yeah.
So six levels at top golf.
We go over to the house.
He has another Craig there.
So that's seven k two more at the Cigar Lounge.
That's nine one at dinner.
Okay.
Uh,
one after dinner with the staff.
Um,
he has a shot where the chaser and then one last one.
So that's cash.
It's an additional one,
two,
three,
four.
So that's what,
well,
let's add it up.
I'm not really good at math.
It's 13,
13 and six.
It's 19,
so,
but times two because those are doubles.
They're all doubles.
30?
Yeah.
Say like 38 drinks.
Wow.
Do you want know how to maniac here?
So it's a lot,
dude.
I made a dinner reservation.
I fucked up.
She's,
I thought it was for later.
So when I,
when I screwed up,
we had to like figure out where to drink until,
well,
no,
we're going to get dinner because it's Sunday night.
We're like shit.
And every place I look up,
it's closed.
So we finally find there's a Ruth's Chris aware,
Ruth's Chris,
Chris Ruth's Chrysalis.
Carl's Jr.
There's risk,
Chris.
We go there and he's,
when he,
uh,
he goes to the bathroom,
when he comes back,
he's like,
I don't know,
he's a little,
I'm gonna try the bread,
man,
it's hot.
He was like,
okay.
And then the whole like five people from the staff come back and they're like,
oh my God.
He got recognized and told them,
Hey,
wait like two minutes,
then come back and recognize me in front of them.
So they're like,
Bird,
oh my God,
we're such big fans.
Okay.
But then they were like talking about your mom's house.
They like odd personality jam.
What?
Like they're all just fans of podcasts and standup.
But he had them come back and like act like they were,
they recognized us.
It's so weird.
Holy Shit.
Um,
and then we hung out with like,
he was like hanging out with the staff and I'm like,
what are you doing?
And he's like,
this is this the best.
I was like,
if you do this after every show,
he's like,
yeah,
just sits there and shuts it down.
Just keeps drinking and
well,
that's what it is.
Maybe it's the drinks that keep flowing past closing.
Yeah.
He just likes to keep the party going.
He's a lot of fun.
When we went to the game,
we got stuck in line outside and he turned that into like a party,
just like yell and Shit to people.
One guy was yelling at him like,
fuck you man,
because we skipped a bunch of people.
And uh,
because of your ticketing or you just were just,
no,
we were jerks.
I paid,
uh,
I paid a guy a smart,
yeah,
but
we couldn't get up that far,
but we did get to skip a bunch of people and this guy was really pissed.
Him and his dad,
he was probably,
I don't know,
late twenties and his dad was late fifties and he's a little guy and he was
like,
mother Fucker,
get the fucking line,
like really get really aggressive and bursts like,
dude,
we're on television.
We have to get in there to work.
And like making it seem like we're with the production crew.
And uh,
when we didn't get any further,
the guy's like,
what happened?
Your television?
And he's like,
dude,
Google me,
I'm on TV.
And the guy goes,
what's your name?
And Burgos Thompson,
Hoorah jerk.
And the guy goes,
your name is piece of shit.
Oh my gosh.
And he's like,
hey dude.
He goes,
you're talking a lot for a little guy.
Like,
and I could feel the tension and eventually died down.
But it definitely was a,
uh,
a pretty heated moment.
Wow.
Um,
this reminds me,
by the way,
I saw the Tonya Harding movie yesterday.
I,
Tonya,
it's the fucking best movie on the planet.
And when I go back to the theater and see it with you,
I'd watch it again.
Really?
Dude,
it is so God damn funny and good.
And if you grew up with a fucked up family,
you're gonna love it.
You're going to laugh your tits off anyways.
Tonya Harding,
his mom is a real piece of shit.
Yeah.
And she would push her to be a winner.
She used to pay people to heckle Tanya right before she would get up to skate,
like literally tied to be walking to get on the ice.
And the mother would pay a heckler.
It'd be like you fucking white trash you piece of shit.
Go back to the trailer because it would motivate her to,
to,
to escape with more fire over.
Isn't that hilarious?
Yeah.
It's so funny.
That story.
I remember how dominant that story was.
That was like the,
sorry.
You gotta see this movie with me?
Let's [inaudible] at all or no,
at the very end they show clips of her,
but the movie's based on interviews done by the husband and her and the people
in the controversy.
It's,
it's so fascinating as a person.
She's got another like foreign,
by the way,
a foreign cursor.
Oh,
good guy.
Gambling.
Aw Jeez.
Oh Fuck Jesus.
Fuck Maloney.
KIP does.
Ah Jeez.
Oh
God.
Jeez.
Is that good curses though?
Yeah.
I've never those I've never heard.
I've heard.
Fuck Jesus.
Maybe a fuck Christmas.
Fuck Christmas.
We learned two new ones.
Dot.
Ponton fuck Christmas today.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Fuck off.
Hey Jeez.
I love this person.
Fearfully recording the guy cause you know,
he's like a little timid,
right?
This guy's about to blow a gasket.
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck,
fuck.
Fuck.
Next door.
That's kind of fantastic.
That is good.
These machines depressed me though.
I'm going to start going with that.
Where do you think he's from?
Luck.
GS.
US Scott Ireland.
You think this guy's Irish?
You think English is his native language or Italian?
Know what?
Fuck Jesus.
Come on.
You gotta listen here.
But he's doing a lot of and maybe Italian.
No,
he's not Italian.
Oh fuck.
Fuck off.
Fuck.
It's Italian next to go next door.
Next door.
He's Malaysian.
No,
cause like I,
like I said,
just next door to Ireland.
It's the same thing.
It was nice.
So those machines suppress you.
They're always in the most depressing place.
Is the machine that he's playing,
like the screen with the roulette on it or whatever like Oh,
it's really,
it's really depressing.
Yeah.
There was in bars or like bad bars or going to a bar where this,
the guys putting the dollar in the poker thing.
Yeah.
You just know that like their life is horrible.
Horrible.
And there's a walker or somewhere.
Yeah.
I don't like it says,
uh,
Hey Taylor,
this is for Tom.
I was wondering if you've ever been a log or a log or is someone who takes a
shit then stands up and tries to cut the Turd and half with your piece dream.
It's fun and has tried to keep it high and tight.
Tim as well.
Tim,
I got some news for you.
I am a blogger,
but no,
not that kind.
I was a lead logger on reality shows,
which means that you log the footage.
Right.
That was one of my first production jobs here in Los Angeles.
I've never stood up to cut my shit and half of the pieces cut.
I mean,
your p stream would have to be so laser powerful.
It gets that way sometimes.
Oh,
it does it.
Yeah.
If it's backed up,
if you're backed up,
oh,
I see you p hard.
Hard.
Yeah.
It's exciting.
It's fun,
but then your pool would have to be really soft that day,
right?
Not necessarily.
You can be really hard sometimes,
Huh?
Yeah,
but you have to hold your pee during your pool,
which is more of that,
especially if you really have to be really awesome.
Yeah.
Especially if you're like cause usually what will happen if you really have to
pee,
pee and poop.
No,
stop it.
You'll have to read favorite top or at least some p and then p again.
That's always been my conundrum in life is how come I sit down and IP I've
finished paying and then you poo but then you make more pediasure.
Boy.
Yeah.
You didn't get it all out that's why.
No,
I think he was out but I think,
I think I've made more pee during the pool.
It's possible but it's really like,
I think that is the whole muscle is not telling him.
Yeah.
We got to ask the doctor drew.
Yeah,
we'll save it blue man.
Are we going to see him to get out of it?
Possibly on Friday a blue band making note of that.
Questions for drew,
the Poo Pee Pee Poop pee question and I making more p or is it just that I
didn't antsy my bladder the first time a mommy's.
I was listening to a recent episode and heard the measure of nail clipping in
public.
I immediately knew I had to email you.
My friend recently decided she wanted to do something special for her mom's
60th.
She spent way more than she should have to take her mom to a show on Broadway.
They sat in the third row.
At one point,
her mom pulls out the clippers.
No,
it's trimming her toenails.
They read that correctly.
Well,
my friend shoots or the,
what the fuck are you doing?
Look,
her mom tells her at full volume.
It's dark.
No one can see me and this is boring.
Anyway.
Oh my God.
Needless to say,
she was absolutely mortified as her mother proceeded to clip all 10 nails
through her open toed mom heels.
They haven't spoken since they got back home.
Michael.
That's horrifying.
It's depressing.
Yeah.
I mean,
she's as Christ that mom,
I don't know.
You can't teach that.
You can't raise that.
No,
it's not.
Okay.
Why don't you be embarrassed to cut your toenails and public to period.
Yeah.
In Brighton at a Broadway show.
I'm embarrassed to do it in front of you.
I always closed the bathroom door and then I do it quietly.
I don't.
That's really,
really fucked up.
You don't seem to mind cutting your toenails in front of me or the,
I don't.
I don't mind that I mind.
Why do you mind?
I don't like seeing you do it necessarily.
What does it make you feel?
I'm afraid of it flying at me or just,
I don't like to see you doing it.
One leg up on the saint kind of,
you know?
I never would do it in public.
Ever.
Never occurred in the sky million years to do that in public.
That's disgusting.
I don't mind doing it on the bed.
That's wrong.
That's not wrong.
Why is that wrong?
Why don't you do it where you sleep and then you're going to lay in the and the
shavings or whatever or all you dogs won't get it.
They don't chew that should I do.
It's just,
it was good.
Nice textured here.
Fif hates the farts.
I've asked you to trim mine for years and you've never done it.
Could.
That'd be something we work on.
We work on that.
You think?
No.
Hey scrums,
do blind people have standards since they can't glass would lose soup lady be
gross to them.
Hmm.
Holiday talked about that.
Blind people can touch your face and feel what you look like.
So that's how they see your face.
So of course,
yeah,
of course.
They definitely have standards.
They could touch your face.
Oh,
you're ugly as shit.
I bet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
She's uh,
do identical twin sisters get their period for the first time at the same time?
Tilden.
Wow.
That's I really good thought provoking.
I don't know anything about like the intricacies of how that would work.
I know that like twin sisters,
no,
I thought I had,
I'm sorry.
I think I'm co-joined twins.
I was thinking of that.
No,
no,
but I know,
isn't there a thing that like women who spend time together,
we'll,
absolutely.
Why is that happen?
Absolutely.
I mean,
I don't think,
I don't know if,
I don't know if there's a medical,
it's hormonal.
It's pheromonal.
So like a home with three women in it will sync up and they'll all have it at
the same time.
Yes.
Let it.
Okay,
so one of whoever is the dominant female will lead the pack.
Whoever's on with the birth control pill,
her cycles regulated,
the other women will follow the one who is on the pill.
It's just,
it's the hormones.
Pheromones.
You pick it up and it's absolutely true.
I wonder what the utility in having it all at the same time,
I would imagine something nature to do,
like being in a village and everybody being fertile,
the women at the same time.
Maybe they could bring up children together at the same time or a no,
that's an all three.
Yeah,
it's the same week.
That's how you wouldn't say that,
but yeah.
Scientifically they could all bust nuts.
Yeah.
Uh,
and all these checks.
Yeah.
I think it would be like,
yeah.
I want to with Michael over there with you,
I wonder am I get a little bag with you and you don't make it a little bit with
you keep fucking all the different girls.
Yeah.
I imagine it's for that reason.
Sure,
sure.
Cool.
Here's a,
let's see what this says.
One more email here.
Uh,
when you have a lot of gas,
your colon swells up and pushes against the bladder,
which causes you to piss abnormally frequently.
When I eat refried beans and drink ice tea,
my two favorites,
I spent an entire day pissing farting like a motherfucker.
Those are your faves.
Just helps James Hope this helps.
What?
That's the email.
This helps.
It says far.
It's pushed the piss out.
Oh Wow.
The West asked about that.
You need a little more context here.
I don't know.
But listen,
the ice tea or caffeinated to makes you pee more.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Um,
yeah.
Very interesting.
Alright.
Mispronouncing words.
This is what I've been fascinated with.
Mommy's on an episode of four 29 with Josh Wolfe.
You're talking about having foreign parents who say wrong shit.
Sit wrong.
My mom is Hispanic.
My Dad is Caucasian.
Both say stuff horribly wrong.
Even though my dad only speak English,
so that's my favorite kind.
He says pigs died.
Not Pig sty.
When a room is a mess.
Yeah.
Write that one down for the act pigs dive pigs died.
Okay.
Is it like,
like fucking nonstop no matter how many times I correct them,
still says it.
I'm also 100% retarded because I thought that vapor rub was Bape or rub because
that's how my mom has said in that accident
every fucking year they realize it's vapor rub.
Totally.
Anyways,
if you want to move in and you can move and you just got to fuck me,
right with Dr drew says far it's 100% push the sheds out.
Will that Bape or rub?
Yeah,
I could totally board rob.
Of course vapor rub.
Yes,
of course.
Yeah.
Um,
I actually,
we had this debate too.
We were farting together and I had to shit after I had farted a lot.
And you know,
I don't know if doctor trues entirely right.
We can challenge him.
He's not like the official,
but wait a minute.
Cause how can a fart signal that you have to shit then there has to be a causal
relationship.
What he said was they can okay
her together.
Right.
Was like that could absolutely happen at the same time,
but they are interdependent of one another.
Right.
They,
they're not necessarily connected,
in other words,
the Lord and to shit.
They can have their own life.
But I feel like every time I fart a lot,
I have to shit that it,
it's,
it's signaling that I need to go shit.
It's really interesting.
An interesting thing to talk about,
um,
being taste tests was a jelly bean taste test.
No,
I know where this is going on.
You haven't seen it.
I don't like it.
I don't like this already.
Yeah,
I didn't know.
that's bad.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it and I knew it would fucking leave there.
I didn't know.
No,
I didn't.
I swear I didn't.
I didn't know.
It doesn't say that anywhere on here.
It doesn't say it on here.
Very disappointing.
I did not know that.
You know,
I have to talk about this,
that this is a thing I didn't know it was on there.
I swear.
Look,
I'm not looking,
I'm not putting my headphones on.
Just opened this.
I didn't see that.
I swear to you.
I didn't see it.
All right,
closed.
I'm going to take you in to my therapist.
So you can hear me talking about my problems with barfing.
Okay?
Okay.
All right.
I'm not going to put this on because I don't trust you to come on.
We've lost my train.
I just didn't do it.
I didn't do it.
That was not my idea.
I swear to you.
You're telling me you didn't do it,
but you're operating the soundboard.
You're the one choosing the clips.
So how can you not know it was,
I didn't see the clip before.
I swear I didn't.
I,
all it says is Barf clip because it Barf,
clip
look,
Jelly bean taste test.
That's what it says.
All right.
I didn't know.
Didn't know it said that.
Um,
this lady,
I actually saw a remix of this ladies.
You saw it too because you're like,
what is wrong with you?
I was watching the remix.
Your put your things on it.
Nope,
Babe,
I'm not playing that.
Don't trust you.
Lost Trust with you.
I promise.
I promise you.
Yes.
I swear on my phone dies.
I won't play that thing.
This lady was,
uh,
I remember.
Do you remember this?
Cause you're,
you're not going to see this song version.
Just the Independent.
There is no god,
but God is real.
I come home drunk from school.
Lay level means I'll be a prostitute,
having oral sex with my mouth,
licking his ball.
The pastor just took the mic away.
You can't see like she's Kinda fucked up I think.
I think she's still drunk.
She's still like in men's balls and then a
Suede,
the remix.
God,
you know what I'm talking about?
No,
of course you don't made because I'm 41 and I don't pay attention to the kid
stuff anymore.
It is not a kid thing.
Responsible Adult Babe dealt responsibilities.
I reposted it because he took that video.
He's the same one that did the,
um,
what's that?
That white girl who was on Dr Phil.
Remember how about that?
Yeah.
So stupid.
The the hose.
The hose outside.
What was that?
I forget.
It's so stupid.
It is pretty stupid.
But anyways,
he took that lady giving that testimony in church.
Hi,
my name is [inaudible] and I'm on back side or y'all pray for me.
I just come home drunk from school.
Great.
Okay.
Pray for me.
Right.
For me.
I can watch those all day.
I can't do it.
Never gets tiring.
This is why the Internet was created for this time that for their stupid remix
remix is one of my absolute favorites.
Two Thanksgiving's ago I got greens,
beans,
tomatoes,
potatoes.
I love it.
He is really good.
He's really good.
I don't even know the guy's name,
but I like it.
Yeah.
Um,
speaking of there is a no,
somebody made in that whatever vein,
the,
that,
that lane of taking a remix and then cutting video to the music,
you know,
which is what that was.
Somebody did that with machines within [inaudible] machines within the c
machines within,
where's it say fall falling knives featuring DJ poly fluid bond mix
in my head over the weekend.
A lot of people,
a lot.
I feel like it's not that bad.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh wow.
Pretty good man.
Machines would,
that guy,
this guy,
that actual singer,
you know,
we send them a send them a check.
Yeah.
So he,
he got his check and bread for the shirts and then he was like,
I get some shirts now we're setting up some shirts too talented.
I wonder what is next song will be though.
It wouldn't be hard to find out.
Let's see.
Working on,
well I dunno,
I'll make sure to to find out.
Oh,
speaking of,
um,
so yeah,
thanks everybody that got machines within stuff and um,
you know,
the Christmas stuff.
But then,
so last year we did,
during the wintertime we did our gene hoodie try out and a lot of people liked
it.
It was,
it was a big hit.
But one of the things that people,
us,
they were like,
oh,
I wish
you had a zip up.
I wish you had a zip up.
It's the why IMH zip up Hoodie.
Oh,
it looks so it's very soft.
Um,
Esop does the Gene Hoodie?
Yeah,
it is a soft,
is that,
it's a zip up though.
So tried to do it because many people asked for a,
uh,
a zip up hoodie.
And then,
uh,
to go with the new special,
I have a,
um,
a,
a a t shirt.
I'll just let you find it.
It's up there and watched the special.
And then if you like it you can get that.
And I have like,
awesome.
I have a couple other shirts coming within the next couple of weeks and I also
have,
um,
we're working on mugs,
so there's some,
some mugs coming about just stuff in the store or go to a merchant
method.com/tom Segura or just go to time square.com and go ahead and just hit
store.
Um,
but just stuff there.
I also have a store on my website,
Christine and p online,
uh,
shirts from my special as well.
You may find them so you can find those there and you can um,
put them,
you can put them in your,
but if you get the,
yeah,
why would you say that?
I don't know.
Why not?
Um,
you know,
the zip ups totally different than just a pullover.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Then the kangaroo pouch,
it's a gear.
It's like two different vibes.
Totally.
It's totally different vibes.
When I'm going just full travel dot B day,
I liked the kangaroo pouch gene,
solid item.
Put your cell phone up front pocket.
And if I'm feeling a little,
a little low,
want to jazz it up,
the zip up instead of a zipper and luck.
It's a totally different look.
Apparently there's um,
something happening online where listeners are saying,
hey,
blue bland.
We're,
we assume you're in charge of reading all our boat bullshit.
Um,
there's a,
a debate as to the origins of blue band and some people have been commenting on
the Facebook group and it says like,
Yahoo is blue band.
Has anyone ever seen him?
Um,
someone who says he's sleep standing up in the mommy's bedroom closet.
Others say he spends most of the time at a local bowling alley,
deejaying a children's parties in exchange for room and board.
No one knows about his background.
Uh,
one frigid November evening when Tommy was out for a walk,
he heard frantic splashing from a nearby reservoir and he went and he saw a
commotion and there was a soaking wet blue van fighting for his life.
And a t band snapped into action,
dove into the freezing water,
grab blue band with one arm paddled to shore.
Since that fateful evening,
blue band owed his life to Dj dad mouth and is therefore you're bound to serve
the mommy's until his final breath.
Hmm.
Um,
he could,
let's see.
Um,
blue band is doomed.
Isolate farts from youtube clips,
sift through listener and submitted email.
I heard he had a double pipe classic one time.
It's very rare.
I don't know.
Do you want to comment on the origins of Blue Band?
Yeah,
very elaborate story.
Yeah.
Um,
but it's close.
It's close to the truth of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
he does live in a nest.
Yeah.
Uh,
but it's on a Saatva mattress.
The lumen leaf collection.
That's true.
And it's in a tree.
It's an entry is one of the few people that doesn't mind putting a mattress up
in a tree.
Most people would be like,
isn't that gonna fall out of the tree?
Not a few.
Set it up.
Right.
Yeah.
You ever seen a fucking tree house before dummies?
So,
uh,
he does sleep in a tree.
He is,
he does have feathers.
I don't know.
He's blue.
Yeah.
One more.
Do you need to know guys?
That's pretty,
pretty much the whole story.
Yeah.
Secret identity.
Little secret.
You guys,
he was on a show.
He's been on.
He's been,
he's been,
he's been here,
but I don't think we've shown his face.
No,
it's for good reason.
He has a severe scarring on his face.
He doesn't like to be seen in public.
Yeah.
Um,
it says here that the hub could help a notice.
Christina has whiter teeth and yes,
you're right.
Keep it tucked,
Rick.
Well,
I know you'd be happy to see that gene.
Thank you.
I did make me happy and my teeth are whiter than yours,
but I do feel as though I work at it a little more than you.
Yeah.
At oral hygiene.
Generally at oral hygiene.
Yeah.
You're pretty committed.
You don't really brush.
I have watched you.
You just do a very cursory sloppy,
like our toddler brushes.
No,
that's not true.
I have a timer on it.
Huh?
I have a timer so it goes right.
I think it was like,
have at times it.
I've watched you.
It's not good.
Yeah,
it is.
He brush like a two year old.
No,
I don't.
Yeah,
no.
Hey,
I
an observation that's going to make you feel a lot better about yourself.
Are you ready?
Sure.
I was sitting watching a documentary about some crazy person or something and
then it occurred to me that I like mental illness too,
as do you,
but you like murderers.
You like serial killers.
I just don't like the killing stuff,
but we both like people with fucked up psyches.
I mean,
that's kind of the glue of this whole show is you and I both laugh at the
mentally challenged Weirdos of the world.
Right?
I don't think that's true.
Oh,
fuck me.
I've talked to Florida,
but what I'm saying is I think we,
uh,
you know,
potato Patato I think we'd been arguing two sides of the same coin here.
I,
I've been judging you,
uh,
with your love of murder shows,
but the truth is you like abnormal psychology and so do I.
But I,
but I just don't like the violent,
I don't like the killing stuff.
True.
But we both like psychos.
We weirdos.
It's
fucked up.
[inaudible] I'm a Martian.
Yeah.
Like I love fucked up psyches.
I think it's one of those fans too.
Thanks.
[inaudible] is the glue that holds the show together,
right?
I mean,
if you really didn't have any,
um,
interest in that,
this podcast when you won't work
well,
a marriage wouldn't work.
Uh,
I dunno.
You could probably still find a way to make the marriage work.
You'd be so bored with me if I didn't laugh at the same stuff you did.
Real.
It's true.
You laugh at everything up until violence,
right?
Yeah.
Because I'm a,
I'm a mother.
I've given life and to me it's just,
I can't watch people dying.
It's too hard.
Yeah.
Not like guys,
you guys kill each other.
Blow Shit Up.
We make life.
Women are the opposite of that were destructive.
Yeah.
It gets your fucking crazies.
Yeah,
we're too aggressive.
Testosterone Cube.
Bloody bloody fuck you bloody oh bloodied up blondie.
Yeah.
Bloody fucking bloody.
Bloody [inaudible] has so great.
And then the very casual.
What the fuck man?
What a vogue bad.
My teeth are so much wider though.
You do have great teeth.
I know.
Let me tell you though.
I worked for many years.
I had really bad teeth growing up.
This is braces,
headgear,
retainers,
veneers,
you name it.
White nurse.
God Damn,
you got really good stuff there too.
It's like my best.
I would say the good thing about your teeth is that once you get them all nice
stuff like this,
you just got to maintain.
Yeah.
My parents,
I know,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
today.
Yeah.
Dang.
They bought a new house,
like it's their final house.
Like we're never going to move again.
I was like,
why is that?
oh cause you're going to die there.
Your Dad's pretty open.
He's like,
yeah,
pretty much.
Your dad is very accepting of his mortality.
I found they do this,
this
thing now this is just aging where they call and talk to me about like the most
boring thoughts and,
and no just things are doing.
Like he calls me,
he's like,
well we're a boxing up some stuff now for the move.
And I'm like,
like I'm waiting for the important information.
yeah.
He's like,
and then uh,
tomorrow movers will come.
Yeah.
That's what happens at over to a new place.
I know that you're moving cause we've been talking about it.
Is there a point to this call though?
He's like,
wow.
Oh then nail a set us up and uh,
then it's a new place after that I'm like right.
The concept of moving is not above my capacity to understand things.
Yeah.
Anything else?
He's like got the uh,
which the cable off.
Got a new cable provider.
We're going to go back to direct TV and a male and got new new address because
we're moving now.
Mike,
no pool,
which is good.
Never used the pool even though it's Florida.
We just didn't use it like a,
all right.
I think
we're good to go.
Yeah.
Fuck.
He just needs to like more people to talk to them.
Yeah.
I think this is why I can't participate in 99% of the conversations that exist
on earth.
Yeah.
I can't find,
I can't do it.
I can't hear people's,
the banality of their daily existence now.
What's the phrase he's been saying to you for last year though?
Tally in mother and I.
Oh yeah.
It's been saying this every call.
I was like,
Tommy and I are getting ready for the next chapter,
next phase of our lives with retirement.
He's retiring at the end of this year.
Wow.
Yeah.
So mother and I are thinking,
so he goes on these fans,
I guess everybody does well,
you know,
everybody goes like,
what are we going to do over the holidays or whatever,
like,
and then you fantasize about your retirement,
you know,
like,
yeah.
He's like,
well,
I think we're going to do is I'll rent a car and we'll just drive because we
have nothing tying us down,
you know,
no job.
So we'll just be able to drive all these places.
Your mother's never been,
you know,
uh,
the Grand Canyon.
Okay.
Uh,
Vermont from Florida.
All right.
He's gonna drive from Florida was like,
we could just leave,
you know,
uh,
six weeks at a time.
[inaudible] so I go,
yeah.
And then he tells me this 500 times they come out for Christmas and I go,
mom,
are you excited about your road trips coming up?
She just closes her eyes as if to say,
I've heard this and I hate it.
And then,
uh,
I go,
so do you realize the kind of what he's talking about?
Like how long I go?
Because,
you know,
he can,
he does.
He won't do like 10 hours of driving.
So he's talking about driving like maybe like four hours one day,
five hours from south Florida to the Grand Canyon.
I'm like,
so the first day,
the first night you spend the night in Florida,
the second night,
I dunno,
maybe you make it to Mississippi,
maybe you know the third.
So I'm like,
you're talking about at your pace,
eight days going out there and she's like,
what?
And he's like,
yeah.
And then I see her goal,
she goes,
I'll meet you there.
And then I just saw his fantasy that he talked about for a year.
Collapsed in one conversation,
but also I wanted to go.
Then you ever like think about talking to her about it?
Like I feel like you just had this fantasy that you never even pitched to her.
It sounded like news to her.
She was like,
Horace,
it's news to her because you've been telling me the fantasy for a year.
And my first thought was always,
why would a 70 year old woman want to sit in a car for eight hours a day for
weeks?
It's just doesn't sound like fun for her.
He was like,
yeah,
no.
She's like,
He's like,
oh,
like hey,
you need a whole new,
I think he just wanted to have,
you know what I needed.
He likes plans.
Yeah.
He likes knowing that what
the plan is and now it's like,
hey,
there's no plan again.
He's like,
fuck,
now what?
Yeah.
Maybe if they got like a mobile home.
Absolutely.
Dot.
She won't do it 100% no,
that's it.
A little better.
At least she could lay down and play with the dog or whatever.
No happen.
It's like a,
that's a,
to me that's my nightmare.
Like that's like being a feature act again.
That's all I did was drive for weeks and months and it's terrible.
It's a nightmare.
I hate that and like staying in motels,
like they'd have to find shelter every night.
They get different city like crazy.
Really a bad idea for two old people,
let's say at the red roof.
Emily,
she's not going to want to do that.
I know.
Really crazy
boy.
What a nightmare.
Total nightmare.
It sounds horrible.
They just cruise drive across the country.
She's like,
what?
I can't think of anything working.
You're going to train ride.
And she's like totally excited about it and not neither.
I would not take a train ride to d c he's like,
yeah,
it's not,
it's not that nice.
Uh,
but it's fun and I see her going like,
it's not fun.
It's not,
it's so boring.
Like I think,
cause I've traveled already,
I've driven,
I've driven through the entire us.
Like I got it,
I get it.
How long are you gonna spend in DC?
And he goes,
uh,
three nights I think.
And I go,
that's not in a lot of time to see all the things they have in DC.
Why don't you stay longer?
When I see my mom looking at me and she goes to a,
went to paper and I go,
why don't you say like five minutes?
You can really see all the museums and then you took the train back.
He goes,
no,
he's,
I think we'll fly back.
You know,
it's expensive.
I go take the train back.
You already took it there and take it back.
Just to get up.
Take your time,
enjoy the terrain and take a detour.
Take the train.
See where else the train goes.
He goes,
other rooms,
other places.
That's horrible.
You know.
So funny.
So great.
And they should go to Europe.
You will see a dad boner.
Yeah.
See what's going on
or case on right now.
And there's literally a kangaroo getting ready to fucking jump buys.
Yeah,
we're are the,
how would they see you?
Why are you talking about,
it's like American guys.
No,
there can't be a king.
There is.
Oh no,
that's nutty.
It doesn't say where it is,
but that is a total,
let's see.
That's a well earned reaction.
He's in the u s that's pretty naughty.
I think.
Almost anywhere you see a kangaroo we're running by.
You flip out pretty Rad.
That was pretty Rad.
What about a dad boner watching a cat?
No,
I saw this one.
This is dumb.
I don't like this one.
I like this one.
This isn't a dad,
but this is a cat.
Also.
Everyone who likes our Facebook page,
we'll be invited to a special Lego town event that's not open
his mouth
throws the cat here.
Yeah,
he's like me.
He's that guy reminds you of me or no?
No.
Why?
He's way more sexual than you.
Like the sexual energy is just oozing off of that guy.
You rude,
rude as hell.
Um,
all right,
well that's it.
All right.
Okay.
Why does your dad,
did we talk about this last time?
Why is your dad makes so much noise when he sits up?
Like I noticed that he would just be sitting,
he would be like kind of laying back on the couch and they are,
why the noises?
Like does it
hurt?
There's a lot of things I want to ask him.
Why?
Why do you do that?
Huh?
He's so hard.
He really is.
He's odd also so comfortable being himself.
I know.
I love him.
I think that's why he's so awesome and he really fits into our life.
Like you were gone and it was just the three of us.
Topdog LJ and I and l j went down for a nap.
I wanted to take a nap and he just chilled on our couch and watch like a warm,
yeah,
he's the best.
I came down and he's like,
Christina,
you know ls as jazz.
The acute has like he got into that whole thing.
Yeah.
He just,
all he wants is like a little bit of snacks.
Like you have to give them some treats every now and then.
His coax,
some TV and he's happy.
It's true.
He's so chill.
He's the best.
He's actually really cool to have around.
I kind of wish he would just live on our couch.
I don't mind at all.
I know.
That'd be fun.
He's the sweetest.
I think we'll continue to see them twice a year though.
That's just where it's going to go.
Yeah.
That's too bad.
Especially now that they're going to be gone all this time.
Chapter,
next chapter is going to be nice.
All these road trips.
I so too,
I like have to stay,
stay out here for a little while.
You know,
they don't know what the whole time they were here over Christmas,
they just went to the mall every single day.
I know we're,
you know,
there's Malibu,
right?
Like there's the ocean.
It was,
the weather was beautiful and they were like,
we're going to the mall.
Okay.
So we did Maui,
I guess were related.
Um,
thanks again for listening.
Please check out.
Like I said,
the new special Friday,
disgraceful.
Also mother inferior is on Netflix.
That's Christina's special.
You can come see us live.
Christina p online Thompson,
[inaudible] dot com.
Thank you again for all your support and uh,
we'll see you next week.
Next few weeks we have guests.
Um,
then we'll do a couple of weeks without,
you know,
we go back and forth.
But thanks again.
Always as always for listening,
watching the show.
All right,
goodbye everybody.
This is a diseased Mommy's by Chris Spence and your ego.
You need closeness of other humans to develop the mechanism for emotional
regulation.
Cha Cha,
Cha Cha.
Oh Hi.
But at the end of the day,
what is the race?
Any ways your family could lie?
We are,
why are we all here on this one?
I was supposed to be equal.
It just made me pass.
People was messed up and stuff.
Oh,
hi John.
Down.
Calm down.
Oh,
honey.
Oh No.
Is that not pretty for your show?
Uh,
for this show,
nuts,
nuts.
I'm trying to get away,
but I was restrained out.
Help to be able to finally distinguishing between true mental illness and
ordinary misery dots,
dots,
trying to get away,
but I was restrained one more time.
So disease is a complex relationship between the substrate and the environment
that results in an abnormal state of physiology,
reflected in signs and symptoms that follow a predictable pattern,
but call natural history,
but a predictable response to treatment.
Yeah.
Bunch of guys.
Enjoying each other's company.
Making this happen to me.
Hello?
Okay.